تعرضت لموجتين على الأقل من
الضربات الصاروخية التي استهدفت
منطقة صناعية ومباني إدارية مما
تسبب في وقوع عدد من الإصابات
بين الشباب، لكن في
الوقت نفسه كان الروس يردون
على بلدة كونستانتينيفيكا مما أسفر عن
مقتل اثنين من المدنيين بما في ذلك
فتاة تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا تتعرض لضربات صاروخية هناك،
والفرق هو مدى
الصواريخ المستخدمة، ومن الواضح الآن أن
الأوكرانيين تمكنوا من الوصول إلى كلا
الصاروخين اللذين صنعواهما
بأنفسهم، صواريخ كروز التي يمكنهم
استخدامها لضرب عمق خلف الجبهة
خطوط إلى الأراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
أوكرانيا وربما حتى البدء في نهاية المطاف في
استخدام صاروخ كروز Storm Shadow الذي
قدمته المملكة المتحدة.
يتم دمج هذا مع
العمليات النفسية، وغمر
الإنترنت ومنصات الفيديو بالمعلومات
المضللة مرة أخرى، كلها تشير إلى
طريق محتمل لـ  جميع القوات الروسية
مصممة للعمل على أذهان
الجندي الروسي في الوقت الذي
يتقدم فيه الأوكرانيون على الأرض
الآن حول باكموت هناك
خطر من وجهة نظر مجموعة مرتزقة فاغنر
مجموعة المرتزقة الروسية التي
يخشون من احتمال قيامهم بها  سيتم
تطويقها نتيجة
لهجوم مضاد منسق يأتي الآن من
الأوكرانيين، وكل ذلك مصمم مرة أخرى لزرع
الفتنة والخوف بين القوات الروسية
قبل أي شيء قد يشكله هذا الهجوم المستقبلي
ليكون سام كايلي سي إن إن في
شرق أوكرانيا